Britain's Prime Minister Boris Johnson
left hospital to continue his recovery
at his country residence he was
discharged after a week three nights of
which he'd spent in intensive care I
have today left hospital after a week in
which the NHS has saved my life no
question it's hard to find words to
express my debt he paid tribute to those
who looked after him I've seen the
personal courage not just of the doctors
and nurses but of everyone the cleaners
the cooks the health care workers of
every description physios radiographers
pharmacists who've kept coming to work
kept putting themselves in harm's way
kept risking this deadly virus the
number of people who've died in
hospitals after being infected with
corona virus in the UK has now surpassed
more than 10,000 the UK government says
record amounts of personal protection
equipment is in the system but staff
treating the sick say they are still
vulnerable I'm sorry if ministers feel
that they have supplied adequate PPE to
NHS staff but that's simply not the case
of what we are experiencing on the
ground NHS staff don't want to be seen
as heroes we're not martyrs and we don't
want to die in the line of duty
we just want to be protected so that we
could do our job across Europe people
are grappling with this crisis the
number of deaths in Spain rose again
after a few days of dropping slightly no
wonder then that there's no let-up in
efforts to try to stop the spread of the
virus and coronavirus is stalking
Frances care homes killing some of its
residents care workers here face a grim
task trying to reassure the living while
dealing with the debt the Paris funeral
homes and private funeral homes are
completely overwhelmed so it means that
some corpses stay three four days in the
bedroom on the bedroom floor
this weekend should have been one of
coming together for many families and
friends to mark Easter instead many of
Europe's capitals are empty their
landmarks deserted the church is closed
the Pope delivered his Easter Mass in a
much scaled-down service at the Vatican
a hundred thousand people usually gather
in Saint Peter's Square to listen Italy
remains the epicentre of Europe's
coronavirus outbreak other places though
are feeling the full force of this human
disaster
ma Haywood al Jazeera
[Music]